bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur un
rt france est ce qu un confinement de
quatre semaines sera suffisant pour
endiguer cette deuxième vague selon vous
les confinements le chocolat paix dans
l'est l'autre dans une ambiance est à
dire vraiment un confinement de la
population à leur domicile permet de
réduire de façon massive
le nombre de contacts entre les
personnes et ça ça permet de réduire le
nombre de nouvelles infections et par
conséquence le nombre de personnes
malades et le nombre de personnes
malades qui ont besoin d'aller à
l'hôpital et qui ont besoin d'aller en
réanimation mais il faut que la mesure
soit rigoureuse et qu'elles soient
strictement appliquée si si nous
utilisons des méthodes de confinement
beaucoup plus souples elles ne
permettront pas de ralentir la courbe
épidémique à laquelle nous sommes
actuellement confrontés surtout peur
avec la vitesse avec laquelle nous avons
besoin que ce suisse à contrôler nous on
a besoin de quelque chose de fort qui
freine les vilenies actuellement pour
que le système hospitalier ne se
retrouve pas en difficulté est que le
système hospitalier ne soient pas
contraints de refuser les malades
là où nous avons besoin de quelque chose
de plus rigoureux plus rigoureux que ce
qui est en cours depuis jeudi minuit tu
sais ce que vous dites un confinement
confinement qui est plus allégée parce
qu'on a vécu en empruntant au printemps
ça ça n'est pas suffisant
disons que nous nous faisons un pari sur
l'avenir le pari qu un confinement et
gilles pourra marcher
nous ne sont pas certains de ça j'aurais
préféré un confinement plus strictes et
que dans deux semaines la legge que en
confinement plus léger et qu'on soit
obligé dans deux semaines de l'augmenter
je pense que la bonne
la scion va avoir du mal à comprendre
c'est quoi ces mesures qui ont une
faible efficacité regarder la mise en
place du couvre feu s'est soldée par un
échec
il a une ralentissement mais ça n'a pas
permis d'éviter que l'épidémie continue
à augmenter et que le système
hospitalier sont trop beau en difficulté
donc il est indispensable que la
population prenne en main soit
responsable et qu'elle implique de façon
très stricte le confinement qu'elles
réduisent de façon très importante le
nombre de contacts par jour et que le
respect des régles de distanciation et
des règles de prévention de la
transmission soit vraiment très
lourdement impliqué aujourd'hui vous ne
ressentez pas les effets du couvre-feu
qui a précédé ce confinement vous dirais
qu'on a perdu et qu'on est en train de
perdre trop de temps je crains que nous
ayons perdu les deux semaines
précédentes qui étaient deux semaines de
couvre-feu peu ou mal appliqués et qui
ont été un sacrifice ont malgré tout
pour nos commerçants pour notre système
économique et qui n'ont pas permis
d'atteindre l'objectif en termes
sanitaires que nous nous étions fixés
moi je préfère un sacrifice lourd mais
qu'avec un objectif atteint une
réduction réelle de la transmission de
la maladie que une méthode mesure un peu
plus molle et qui ne permet pas
d'atteindre l'objectif mais que par
contre nos commerçants paient et nous
avons malheureusement perdu la connexion
avec enrique casalino chef des urgences
à l'hôpital bichat à paris vous êtes de
retour pour quelle raison à la deuxième
vague s'annonce-t-elle plus meurtrière
je ne crois pas qu'ils sont forcément
plus meurtrière el bayadh comme la
première mais actuellement le choix
politiques et de nous placer sur le
modèle de
la tôle épidémique pendant plusieurs
mois et le nombre de décès cumulés je
pense qu'il sera du même ordre que le
nombre de décès que nous avons vu lors
de la première vague lors de la première
vague nous avons eu à peu près trente
mille décès nous sommes actuellement à
36000 nous en avons déjà fait 6000 en
plus sans être dans une période
épidémique très lourde et le plateau
épidémique pendant plusieurs mois
d'ici la fin de l'hiver regerat
probablement aux alentours de 20 mille
ou 38 décès est-ce que malgré tout la
forte hausse des cas de contamination à
laquelle on assiste ces derniers jours
est-ce qu'elle n'est pas là aussi le
moyen d'attendre la fameuse immunité
dont on a tant parlé
enrique casalino décidément un chef des
échanges très noir dans l'hypothèse
d'une limité correctives
il faut attendre au moins 60 ou 70% de
la population actuellement en france il
n'y a pas plus de 5% de la population
qui était en contact avec le virus entre
5% et 5 60 ou 70%
la différence est trop importante pour
faire confiance à l'hypothèse d'une
immunité collective
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
réagir sur notre antenne américain
casalino chef des urgences à l'hôpital
bichat de paris